absolutely it's heavy it is an antique
1980s television this is back from when
television was furniture I love it well
this is this is my first computer this
is a computer that my parents had the
foresight to buy me when I was 11 years
old it gave me a curiosity about
mathematics and physics which has never
really gone away today I'm going to talk
about the number 15 and I want to tell
you that if you're a computer geek like
me we don't really think of the number
15 is 15 we think of it as the letter F
I'm going to tell you why
right now you've got to get this sound
this just makes such a fantastic switch
on sound in that satisfying so all I'm
going to do is write a short piece of
code that makes the computer count I'm
rather pleased with myself but I can
still remember how to do this tada
so all I'm doing is just counting 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 and then something rather
odd happens and instead of counting to
10 the computer switches to a b c d e f
and then 10 11 12 13 and again it
happens at 19 1 a 1 b c d e f 20 how
bizarre I was baffled I was 11 years old
and we used to have to wait for games to
load from cassettes and when they loaded
they would count and that would take
maybe 10 minutes and so I would be
watching these numbers count very
patiently waiting to play pac-man or
tetris or whatever game I was playing
that day and wondering precisely why it
wasn't just getting on with it and
getting to 10 you know why did it have
to go through it felt like torture
because I wanted to play the game get on
with it count to ten but no we had to go
a through F first of all so what we need
to remember is that computers don't
count the way you and I count on our
fingers they count on lines representing
ones and zeros binary numbers so what I
want to show you is just four lines
first of all and the number zero the
number one the number two number three
and then I'm going to skip a few down
here we're going to go to the number 14
and the number 15
okay so there's quite a few numbers in
between which we've skipped over for
brevity so this is not 1 2 3 14 15 and
and I have to stop there I have to stop
there because we've run out of numbers
if I if I try and count to a higher
number that means that's got to be
naught naught naught naught 1 but I
don't have space for this one here and
so we can't count to a number bigger
than 15 on 4 bits these if you want to
understand the underlying ones and zeros
that's going on in the computer then I
need to be able to very quickly say what
is this number and this number
unfortunately bears very little
relationship to the decimal value so for
example the number 9 this is the number
not for a computer so the number 11
that's number 11 okay or the number 6
for example would be not 1:1 so what we
do instead is we count in a thing called
hexadecimal this is base 16 so if we had
16 fingers then we would have come up
with numbers sufficient to go from 1 to
16 but because we only have 10 fingers
we only have 10 digits for counting and
so instead of using just more digits we
use letters to replace the missing
digits so let's start at the number 8
and we'll work our way through so the
number 8 is going to be 1 0 0 0 that's 8
the number 9 1 0 0 1 that's 9 and then
the number ten that's ten now notice
that in decimal we've had to go into a
new column for the number 10 but if
we're working in hexadecimal
then this is 8 9 and then this becomes
the letter A and then 11 it's 11 and
it's the letter B then we're just going
to skip to the end and it's going to be
1 1 1 1 which is the number 15 or in our
case the letter
F our magic number okay this is magic
because it allows us as programmers to
very quickly see what's going on with
the binary numbers the electronics
inside the computer so in an 8-bit
computer we've got two sets of 4-bit set
so the number zero becomes zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero two lots
of four bits now this this set can be
represented by one hexadecimal digit the
letter zero and just to let you know
that it's hexadecimal I'm just going to
write an X in front of it and this lot
can similarly be represented by the
hexadecimal number zero so this is 10
and this is 10 but in hexadecimal we can
still represent this by a single
character this becomes a and this
becomes a in hexadecimal our number is a
a with little X in front of it just to
tell you that it's a hexadecimal number
so I'm going to skip to the crux of the
issue and that is the top number that we
can store in an 8-bit value which of
course is simply 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1
what number is there and that number is
this is F this is f so we've got the
hexadecimal number F F which is equal to
255 which is the highest value that an
8-bit computer can store ok now of
course modern computers aren't simply 8
bits long
recently 32 bits or you can go out and
you can buy a top-end 64 bit computer so
I want to show you the highest number in
very short hand notation that a 32 bit
computer can store here we go F F F F F
F F F so 8-bits 16-bits 24 bits 32 bits
now write that in binary how I hate you
1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1
have to put a few on the front and that
is the binary number 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1
1 1 1 1 1 1 11 a big number and that's
why we don't use binary we use
hexadecimal values obviously if I wanted
to write a really big number down it's
just too much pen and ink so we don't
use the binary we don't use decimal
because well this number it's not 65,000
it's approximately 4 billion this has no
relationship to 4 billion then they were
obvious way to tell you the two things
together but when we're using the
hexadecimal numbers each character is
simply tied to a block of four binary
values so this character represents the
first four this character the next four
and so it's very easy to just walk along
understanding the number in human
readable chunks